hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend and uh we're gonna have a good
time today I can just sense it in me
bones okay I'm like an old C salty that
way I feel things in me bones and I feel
that this is going to be a good one Sona
how are you I'm good I think if you were
a sea salty I feel like it's not it's
not like a cool easy life though right
no it's not okay all right no I'm a hard
tough man that's grown up on with the
Sea Breeze and me puss
uh the wind blasting across no the uh
stop the ocean what well just I'm just
gonna take issue with some of these
terms what did you just say something in
your puss yeah the old puss the old face
yeah and then you're saying sea salty
that's there's a salt and there's a sea
dog but there's nothing called a sea
salty
oh I'm thinking of the cracker oh I
think it's a cracker called sea salty
that's what you're saying I'm thinking
of a Saltine yeah yeah I think I'm kind
of a I'm like a Saltine I feel things in
my bones yeah dry and I'm Crispy
that no one's really enjoyed since about
1950. eat it when you're nauseous yeah
can you even find Saltines anymore of
course are they out there
because they know that everything got so
specialized every you know you go to the
store and all the crackers are so like
oh this one's made of you know this kind
of seed mixed with that kind of seed and
you know it's all Boutique
nonsense you just need to crumple it up
into your soup and only a Saltine would
work or like an old lady has to have
them in their purse you're hungry he
looks in here
they say that you look big you look sick
oh you look sick and thin yeah that's a
great thing for people to walk around
saying yeah I think I'm gonna say this
and I don't know if you can relate Gorly
because I'm older than you but when I
was a kid I felt like there was if you
wanted a cracker you had a Saltine or a
Ritz or a graham cracker oh I know but
that's different I'm saying if you
wanted like a salty cracker you had salt
I apologize okay great you're really in
my flow today that's terrific okay
incredible I I wish we had a band
together so we could suck at the same
time
anyway
uh my point is there was basically two
types of each kind of food that's what
it felt like to me yeah and if you
wanted a powdered drink you'd get like
do you know what I mean yeah there'd be
like a lemonade there'd be one kind of
lemonade or another kind but that was it
but there's 750 types of each kind of
food now yeah so I that's why I feel
like Saltines must be getting squeezed
out and I worry about them you really
worry about Saltines well I did for a
second now it's gone okay that makes
more sense I mean if you're like staying
up late worrying about something no when
I say I'm worried about something and
this includes worried about like my
parents health or how anyone in my
family or anyone in my life is doing I'm
talking about a momentary Sensation that
quickly passes the second I see my
reflection
although we've been talking about
Saltines for a good few minutes now God
damn it what a great crispy crack I know
they are good you can't beat them well I
think that
that the market on crackers and then
everyone got fat people were like maybe
crackers with better
like cardboard with salt on it coming
out again
I think I like them in my soup oh that's
fine yeah did you guys ever play that
game where you eat a bunch of Saltines
and you try to whistle that was good
times oh and it comes shooting out and
it looks like shrapnel yeah I love that
game yeah we should do that uh nah
what's not okay let's never do that okay
wait a minute I'm gonna tweak your idea
okay slightly okay you should do it too
let's never do it okay so I took what
you said and slightly tweaked uh-huh
yeah we'd be great in a band together
you're right I know trust me yeah you
with your a sousaphone
um me with my sweet Stratocaster and
personality and personality yes I mean
problematic personality hey I'm
America's sweetheart oh no it's true
story it used to be I'm gonna tweak your
story listen Julia Roberts was America's
sweetheart and then they notified me
recently that it has been passed to me
is this like People's sexiest person
alive it's kind of uh but it's not done
by People magazine it was just a given
that Julia Roberts was America's
sweetheart for like 25 years it went
from her to you I swear to God I was as
shocked as you guys were I thought it
was a gas bill and I just opened the
envelope and it said Julia Roberts is no
longer America's sweetheart now it's you
Conan O'Brien and there's all this all
this responsibility who said who sent it
yeah you know what I looked into it and
it seems pretty legit and I don't want
to talk too much about it really oh you
looked into it it seems legit but you
don't want to say who sent was it by any
chance sent by Conan O'Brien it just
said C O'Brien okay yeah it said C
O'Brien and it smelled of smelled of
alcohol so it's possible I wrote it late
at night and mailed it to myself and it
had crumpled up Saltines in it it had
Saltines in it what I thought I thought
it was glitter I was like this is
exciting and I started waving it around
the room clearing house and just
Saltines everywhere but anyway if you're
curious yes I'm now America's sweetheart
oh boy America really is at the end of
its row forget the Democracy thing
forget January 6th forget the threat
against our whole system of democracy I
think this is the end this is the final
blow